now it is time to take longer strides
time for a great new American Enterprise
time for this nation to take a clearly
leading role in space achievement which
in many ways may hold the key to our
future on earth I want to talk about
working with Damien Chazelle this movie
really accomplishes something so
gigantic and overwhelming technically
but something so intimate and meaningful
at all other times how does that
translate for you guys I think that
you're exactly right about what you're
saying because it is a special equality
of Damien's I think and that he's able
to work at these you know on a very
large scale and at the same time he
still is able to keep like the working
environment very you know just creative
and and personal and I think it's
reflected in his movies as part of what
you know what makes them special
I don't know how Ryan did it to be
honest because I I thought we were
shooting one film which is like a small
intimate domestic number and then when I
watched the film I was like he can't he
get that secret and I just went on does
it all very incredibly heroically um but
yeah I don't know how I don't know how
either of you did that
I kept their technical and the emotional
and personal and did them both at the
same time we can touch with one another
what are the chances you not coming back
those kids they don't have a father
anymore great so
gonna sit the boys down and you're gonna
prepare them for the fat you might not
ever come home why we've got whiplash
lollol and now we've got this do you
believe that every movie you make has to
be harder than the last one I don't know
if it has to be but certainly I guess
that's that has been the case so far
this was the hardest thing I've done yet
but I don't know when you're making a
movie about the moon landing you know
it's nothing's ever gonna be as hard as
that so you always feel like you know
you get to benefit from the hard work
those people did and we were just lucky
to be able to tell that story do you
think that there's anything in those
other two particular movies that really
let that taught you things that you used
in this one well you know I think on the
one hand there's a thematic kind of
similarity something I've always been
interested in which is just what the
cost of a goal is you know trying to
pursue a dream what that what the
implications of that can be on the
people who pursue it certainly applies
to this story and in a very large-scale
way the vehicles not safe we need to
fail we need to fail down here so we
don't fail up there the detail in this
movie is outrageous almost like a
documentary was there anything that felt
just really fun and freewheeling to you
like on the opposite end of the spectrum
where you can just kind of let all that
go and just be in the moment
yeah actually like like all your stuff
is very specific and there's actual
footage of those events and everything
and all of my stuff nearly entirely like
there was so little footage of Elliot
see the astronaut that I play a movie
that it was kind of like I had that to
know and then all of the stuff we were
doing was like interpersonal stuff it
was all character development and
seems where it actually was the opposite
of that it was total freeform there were
no marks there were no they would
explain what shots were happening would
just sort of be like all of a sudden the
camera be really close on you and you'd
be doing your thing and then the camera
just be like in the middle of your line
just like and then you know Damien would
encourage like nonlinear performance
like you know if you want to just say
this line and then go get a beer from
the fridge inside like do it because by
the way also everybody inside the house
is doing the scene at the same time like
it was crazy like anything that was
historic
historically like accurate that you can
actually look up and see we would copy
the exact movements but everything else
was much more freeform it was
interesting though because I just would
you you're very alone you're you can't
really hear anyone you have like you
know an ear thing is you hear when they
talk to you but all you hear is kind of
the hiss of the air coming into your
helmet you got itches all over that you
can't scratch and you're just kind of
you're just breathing and you're like
and and you have the pant the panel of
the command module is like right here in
here but that thing is small you are
stuffed into this little teeny tin cans
pretty crazy and we were in there for
hours and hours and I was and you're
strapped in so you can't really move it
was just it was fun though because I
just kind of thought of what they were
feeling like what it felt like to
actually like this is as close as it
gets you know I can see you as we're
taking off there's this massive LED
screen I can see us passing the clouds
and going into this into space and I'm
strapped in and I'm like in the it was
like an incredible experience if you do
sick
5 4 3
do you question whether the program is
worth the cost in money in and last
you're down here and you look up and you
don't think about it too much but space
exploration changes your perception how
did the two of you work together on set
to create that kind of symmetry that for
the shots would have come from the book
right for you guys that was coming from
just personal experience in talking so
we actually we weren't on set together
but because I played Bonnie's mother she
was sort of my my guide in creating the
character and I went down to Dallas and
we met and we have brunch and Bonnie
brought lots of pictures like these and
and stories and just those little
details about a family and the dynamic
that I and then Jason used to bring the
characters away your character was
crafted almost through the eyes of
Janet's children in real life and there
are two of the most interesting people
involved in this whole thing and what
was that like for you they were the
people that I was most and I think one
was about anxious to make sure approved
of what we were doing and never wanted
to feel like I was some sort of like
probe trying to find out about their
childhood because it's precious and and
I knew it was and I wanted to keep it
that way so it was just very important
to me that they recognize their parents
and they sort of on-screen
I mean her performances I sort of I
can't I'm out of superlatives to
describe it it was just so spot-on felt
like I was watching my mom up there I
mean there's so many things he did or
exactly what I think mom would have done
in this same situation so yes he blows
away I mean he's really he's a
phenomenal and and so good at nonverbal
communication I mean it's just really
impressive really impressive performance
I believe that this nation should commit
itself to achieving the goal
landing a man on the moon and returning
him safely to the earth
[Music]
here that the great Damien Chazelle has
sort of a Bible for this movie it's one
of the things that contributed to
exactly how technically amazing and
touching it is all at the same time is
that the case that he had this kind on
set I never saw an actual dimensions our
Bible yeah but I definitely got films to
watch and documentaries to watch sure
and things to look at and listen to
which you don't often get which was just
amazing and gave an idea about what kind
of was gonna happen I mean that's
actually in step with what I've heard
because I also hear he kept it secret
sometimes like it was hard to kind of
even get a peek at it what about you did
you see it ever I read about this in the
press notes as did you I think anything
you learn you know I'm ravenous for
detail three hundred page document for
all departments to be on the same page
about how everything was meant to look
and feel and to be shot it was a work of
art in terms itself whenever I would try
to see what was written it was like
mercy and when he opened it it glowed is
baseless yeah light up like
transcendence you hear whether it be
like stuck and then he open it be like I
know what we're doing I know what to do
we were pulling pictures and diagrams
from the actual crafts so that he would
have visuals so that he could then
communicate that because he was so
focused on accuracy as was I and he
wanted to be able to communicate that to
all the department heads right whether
it was Nathan you know building you know
these these crafts to Mary you know on
wardrobe and we got very specific and
Jim must been going nuts during this
period as I kept calling him with
questions cuz oftentimes David asked
question I wouldn't know right I mean I
researched you know didn't go and
sometimes Jim wouldn't know and so Jim
would refer us but this one or that one
and to try to get even more specific but
yeah it was a humungous document by the
and it was it was sort of a reference
book I think for him and for other
department heads I'm singing here as a
historian very envious of the future
biographer who's gonna be able to write
Dean UniFi story because source
materials I mean gotta make sure yeah
this book and on the book for a lava
land and whiplash yeah all those books
have been saved yeah because they're I
mean I'm thinking of these are we got to
get these make sure they're preserved
because historians of film are gonna
want to know our baby had made his
movies totally so I'm gonna have to live
a lot longer than I planned well I guess
there were two important books in this
movie there was Jim Hansen's book the
movies based on that was definitely a
Bible for us I remember then I mean
there was a few years of just research
that we did on this movie before
shooting and I wound up just compiling
all that research and all the images
inspired me into yeah a kind of booklet
that just started to grow and grow and
grow until it became very unwieldy but
did become I guess another second kind
of Bible but even that scratch the
surface I mean that's the thing with the
subject matter is no matter how much you
learn you're just aware of how much you
still have to learn it's endless
so it was part of the fun but also part
the challenge of the movie for sure did
it get a special nickname that had
anything to do with the baby goose the
baby goose ran gastly yes okay that's
actually how I refer them to yeah take a
moment
yeah we called it the notebook and yes
yes it just needed you to see it
definitely warrants that reaction we
have serious problems
we've got this under control you're a
bunch of boys you don't have anything
under control
I love anytime that we acknowledge the
families behind the astronauts that kind
of get all the glory because it really
is a whole thing like poor everyone
involved is there one story that really
stands out I mean there was the time
that my dad ended up we have special
passes to go to the front of the line
and I guess one of the world's Fair's or
something and my dad noticed that there
was a little crippled child that wasn't
gonna get to go see it was it's a small
world when it first opened up way back
in the day and he went and left us and
went and carried the little crippled
child through the ride and it was just
you know just no he wasn't and I think
when he went up into space he also took
three medals and when was the st.
Christopher one was across and one was a
Star of David and he was thinking about
kind of world unity and world peace
everybody get him along and you know
just something that we're all striving
still to do to this day
[Music]
you